سالنا الناس في مصر برايكم بسبب انتشار
فكره لا نريد انجاب الاطفال بين هذه
الفكره بين بعض الازواج الجدد من جيل
الشباب ما مرضها
[موسيقى]
قوي
فبيحتاجوا وقت مثلا الناس بتقول لك هيتجوز
بعد يعني اخلف بعد سنه لان في ظل الظروف
الاقتصاديه اللي احنا عايشينها يعني يا
دوبك يكفي نفسه قدام عرف يكفي نفسه عشان
خاطر الايام ديت ظروف بقت صعبه جدا
فكل واحد بيفكر ازاي
يعني يتانى في الضغوط الحياه مش هيبقى
جايب طفل تاني
اتجوز مش عارفين بعض ما عرفوش بعض كويس
فده بيخليهم ان هم ممكن ياخدوا القرار ان
هم يعني ياجلوا فكره الانجاب افكر قبل ما
اجيب عيل افكر فيه مره واتنين وتلاته هل
هو هيتظلم ولا هل هيعيش ولا هل ايه اللي
هيحصل وانا عايز اجيب عيل يبقى احسن مني
عيشه تبقى اسوء مني
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات